Hello, and welcome
to "Cloud OnAir,"
our live webinars
from Google Cloud that
happen every Tuesday.
Today we're talking
about the future
of databases in the cloud.
And my name is Deepti
Srivastava I am the product
manager for Cloud Spanner.
So let's get started.
So before we talk
about Spanner and why
we think it's the future
of databases in cloud,
I think it's important to go
through a little bit of how
we got here, all of us-- how
IT and databases and just data
itself got here.
For cloud, it is still
very, very early.
So most of global IT spend,
as you can see from this chart
that we've got
from Gartner here,
from last year's "Gartner
Reports", basically very little
of it is still in cloud.
So each of these businesses and
each of these infrastructures
have a database, right?
You always need
to have a database
to store your critical data
or not so critical data.
So for database spend, it's
extremely early in terms
of cloud adoption.
So as you can see here first
of all, most of database
spend is in operational
DBMSs and very little of it
is actually in the sort of
non-relational open source
world.
Despite all the
sort of marketing
you hear from the non-relational
side of the spectrum here,
they're actually--
most data is actually
stored in relational databases.
And that's sort
of obvious, right,
because with relational
databases you get transactions,
you get atomicity of updates,
you get integrity of data,
you get consistency
guarantees, et cetera,
which are, of course very,
very useful as we all know
for developing applications.
So obviously this implies
that a lot of the databases
out there are
relational and most
of the mission critical
data that a company has
will be stored in
relational databases.
So before we jump into the
growth of relational databases,
it's important to talk
about what we mean
by mission critical, right?
So when we're talking about
mission critical data, what
we really mean is data
that is business critical,
so loss of that data
or even a glitch
in serving that data
affects your reputation
and has financial
risk to your company.
So all of this data
that is required
for you to run your
business is what
we call mission critical data.
And we're saying that
most of that mission
critical data is stored in most
cases in relational databases.
So again, where are we at
with the current status
of databases?
So most companies, as we talked
about earlier, most of the IT
spend is still on prem.
What that means is that
most databases are still
running on prem.
And most companies
are then managing
their own inflexible
database infrastructure
on premises with
an army of people
trying to maintain
that infrastructure,
and maintain their databases,
and keep them alive
and running.
And you know, of course,
there is a huge overhead
in having those.
There are those companies
who have taken the leap
and adopted cloud
to some extent.
And what that means is
they're using infrastructure
as a service from
cloud providers
so they're running
their own database
solutions on top of these
cloud provided infrastructure.
So they're still in the business
of maintaining, managing,
and administering, and
keeping their databases alive.
They may not need to run
the machines themselves
that host those
databases, but they still
have to deal with the database
maintenance and management.
And then there are companies who
have taken a bigger leap where
they're actually
paying a service
provider to manage and run their
database solution in the cloud.
Right.
So this means that
they don't have
to worry about actually
keeping the database alive.
There is a service
that's doing that.
But that still
means that they have
to make sure that the databases
are running the way that's
expected and they have
to deal with the service
provider for their
database service
and maybe deal with other
providers for other services.
Right.
So there is some
complication there.
Now apart from where the systems
and databases are running,
the other limitation is
in technology itself.
So companies are running
into limitations around RDBMS
scale up and scale out
and sharding solutions.
So if you run out of
capacity of your database,
what do you do, right?
You have to either scale
up to bigger machines
or you have to go to
the shard solutions
and they come with
their own headaches,
which we'll get into
in a little bit.
And finally, companies are
dealing with the administration
and consistency challenges
of scalable solutions
that are also NoSQL
or non-relational.
So for those
companies who already
hit the problem with their
databases and the scale of them
and have adopted sort
of more stable solutions
that are NoSQL or
non-relational,
they're trading off
consistency for scale
or the traditional relational
semantics for scale.
They're running into challenges
of having the consistency
issues and the
challenges in running
and in administering these
NoSQL solutions whether on prem
or in the cloud.
But the technology
challenges still remain.
So you know what does that
mean for where we are in terms
of the spectrum of technology?
So we have this very
interesting trade
between traditional
relational databases
and traditional
non-relational databases.
Right.
So on the business side,
traditional databases
provide you with schema,
with SQL, with consistency.
And the NoSQL or
nontraditional solutions
don't provide you those,
but they trade those off
for high availability,
horizontal scalability,
replication, et cetera, which
is the exact limitations
of traditional relational
databases in most cases.
What that means is when you
want to run high availability
relational databases for your
mission critical applications,
you have to create these
highly complex architectures
to provide that availability,
and replication, and disaster
recovery solutions for
your mission critical data.
And as you can see, you're
running multiple masters.
You're running read
replicas for scaling out
and offloading the read-only
data access, et cetera.
You're trying to have Memcache
in there somewhere so that you
can do faster reads
of your data, which
means you have to deal with
the flushing of the cache.
You have to deal with
consistency issues
with having multiple
masters if you need that.
You have backup replicas.
So managing this
system, now you've
gone from one database
that hosts your mission
critical data to this
complicated architecture that,
again, requires an
army to maintain.
You don't actually know
where the bottlenecks
are in some cases, because
the system is so fragile.
And you know, God forbid if
one piece of it somehow fails
and then you have to figure out
what the cascade effects are.
And in most cases,
you don't actually
even know what the
full picture is
because it's become such a
complicated, organically grown
beast.
So going back to
first principles,
like what do customers want?
What do you want
from your database?
Right.
So obviously you want it to be
highly available and scalable.
And you want it to give
you data consistency
so you can access
data confidently
for your application and you can
serve the correct and accurate
data to your customers.
And of course, from a
developer standpoint,
when you're building and
using these databases,
you want simplified operations.
Right?
You want standards.
You want single points
of contact for support.
You don't want to have
to talk to the database
provider, and the infrastructure
manager, and the cloud provider
separately.
You want to have one
person or one contact point
that you can go to if
you have any issues.
So you don't have
to deal with crises
by like being the coordinator of
various pieces in that crisis,
right?
Basically, you
want your databases
to run while you
can build and grow
your application
and your business.
And this is where
Spanner comes in.
So why did we build Spanner?
And how did we get here?
So if we go back
in time to 2005,
technical
infrastructure at Google
had various scalable solutions,
because we had already
reached the skill versus
consistency problem.
Right.
So we had scalable
data storage systems,
but we were lacking
in transactions
and relational semantics
in those systems.
And as we've learned,
as we all know,
those relational semantics, SQL,
et cetera, are very important
and they really help you
run your business well.
So Google reached that point.
And so the need of the
hour was horizontally
scaling databases,
brief ACID transactions,
and global consistency.
And of course, we are Google,
so we want no downtime.
We want high availability.
We want you to be
able to access Google
from anywhere at all times.
So we came up with Spanner.
We developed Spanner
with a lot of research
and a lot of
understanding of how
to build distributed, scalable,
highly available systems.
And what we have here
is basically the paper
that we published in 2012 that
talks about the technology
that we built at the time.
So Spanner was
launched externally
as Cloud Spanner, which is
a publicly available product
on Google Cloud platform.
And it's about
exactly a year ago
that it was launched
publicly on GCP.
So we're celebrating
our first anniversary
as a cloud database.
So Cloud Spanner is basically
an enterprise grade globally
distributed and strongly
consistent database service
built specifically for
the cloud to combine
the benefits of relational
database structure
with non-relational
horizontal scale.
So what does that mean?
We're basically
saying you don't have
to trade off or make compromises
between relational semantics
and horizontal scale, which is
what traditionally companies
and IT folks have had to do,
database users have had to do.
They've had to basically
trade off and give up
on relational semantics and
build that in the application
to get horizontal scale
to manage their data
growth over the
course of the data
exploding it for
their business, right?
So Spanner allows you to not
have to make that compromise.
It's our no compromise
relational database service.
And you get all of this packaged
up in a managed service.
So you can focus
on your database
and not have to
worry about running--
sorry.
You can focus on the
application using that database
and not have to worry about
running the database itself.
So we provide schemas,
asset transactions, SQL,
and the relational scale with
up to five lines of availability
and an availability SLA,
so we guarantee that in
a fully managed, easily
scalable service.
So if we hark back
to our chart of what
are the pros and
cons of relational
versus traditional
non-relational services
or databases,
basically you don't
have to make those tradeoffs.
We have schemas, we have
SQL, we have consistency
like traditional
relational databases,
and we have availability,
scale, and replication.
And by the way, a bunch
of it out of the box
that you can get with
nontraditional non-relational
traditional NoSQL systems.
So again, you don't
have to make compromises
between technical needs
and business needs
in order to really
run your applications
and your business critical data.
Now there are differences
in the technology of Spanner
and traditional
relational databases
and how they've worked so far.
And of course there
is innovation here
that allows us to do this
relational with scale.
And I can touch upon
a little bit of that.
But the important
thing to note here is,
like traditional databases,
you get tables, you get DDL,
you get the same schemas
that you're used to.
So you do create table, you
have primary keys, et cetera.
And in this picture,
you can see that we've
created two different tables,
which have relationships
that you can see.
And you use simple
DDL statements
in order to create this table.
And you'll use this schema
change, DDL statements as well,
to alter Table or drop
column, et cetera as well.
So again, these are
the familiar constructs
that you're used to so far
with the traditional relational
that you get with Spanner as
well with some added benefits.
Right.
So in this case, you
see these two tables.
And if you were to see how this
logical structure is laid out,
Spanner has a concept
of interleaving.
It's one of the many
technical differences,
but it's interesting
to point out
as it kind of
showcases how we've
been built for scale with
the relational transactional
semantics.
So in the previous case, we
had two different tables.
And they're logically different.
There's the albums table
and the singers table.
But if you interleave the albums
table and the singers table,
what that means is that the
data is logically co-located.
So you essentially can
think of it as a pre-join.
So when you're doing a large
data set reads or scans,
you don't have to actually
do the join at a run time.
Right.
You can predetermine
that these datasets are
going to be queried together
and you can logically
tell the system to store
them together so that they
can be retrieved much faster.
Now for a few megs or
a few gigs of data,
joining may not be a
latency causing issue,
but when you have hundreds
of gigabytes or hundreds
of terabytes of
data, and you need
to do all albums for all
singers sort of a query,
that's a lot of data to
be joined and processed
at runtime, at query time.
So instead of having to
do a join at that time,
you can specify to
the system that you
need to pre-join the
dataset because your most
common queries are actually
going to scan the singers along
with their albums.
So in this case, the
system can very quickly
basically read the data and
return the query results
without having to do the
computationally intensive join,
hence reducing read time
or query serving time.
Again, you can use interleaving
for indexes as well.
So we have secondary indexes.
We are a relational database.
And from that standpoint,
you can, of course,
have separate logical
indexes, which
can be standard tables in
other traditional databases.
Right.
And in our case, they are
standard tables as well,
but you can interleave them.
So again, if you're going
to have to back join indexes
with the base table because your
most common query is requiring
that pattern, then you
can interleave the indexes
within the base table.
And again, that can lead to
much faster selects and queries
of your data.
So this is just one of the ways
in which Spanner is different,
but it shows you
under the covers
the technological
differences we have
which allows us to provide
scale with relational semantics.
So as Nick says in this
quote from Gartner,
so when we talked
about-- when we launched
Spanner and we talked about
it with various analysts
and of course we have
customers that are using it,
it's interesting
because it's not just
another take on a
traditional database.
It's really a new
way of thinking,
a new need that's being met by
the technology that's Spanner.
But Spanner is not
just software, right?
It's the combination of a lot
of very clever software, which
there is a lot of, along
with hardware that we've
built specifically for scale and
to provide the kinds of things
that we need for large, highly
available, scalable system
such as atomic clocks
that we have in-house.
Like true time is
a technology we
use for global synchronization
and external consistency, which
is stronger than
linearizability.
So we use true time, which is
based on atomic clocks and GPS,
to do this coordination.
And that powers
Cloud Spanner as well
and allows it to have that
global external consistency,
which allows us to
then have globally
consistent and strong
relational semantics
database in Cloud Spanner.
This is, of course, build on
top of our Google network,
which we've talked
about quite a bunch,
and there is a lot
of white papers
that we've actually put
online as well that one
can read if interested.
But basically,
it's a combination
of our Google networking,
which is highly redundant
and optimized on all levels
from the network fabric
all the way to the
switches to the hubs,
et cetera, and atomic clocks
and GPS with true time
as well as clever software
in Cloud Spanner itself.
So we, for example, have
wrote our own implementation
of Paxos.
We don't use open source
Paxos implementation.
We optimized the Paxos
algorithm in our implementation
for our specific use
case, which allows
us to again do low
latency transactions
and to do strong reads
across continents
and across oceanic links.
And all of this combines
to give you Cloud Spanner.
So there's a bunch of customers
that are using Spanner
and they're excited about it.
I am personally excited to
talk about a few of them
that I've been seeing them win.
And it's really
exciting for us to see
how the world has adopted
and started to use Spanner.
So It's not just about
trading off cap x for op
x, which is what a managed
database service gives you.
That's kind of the
promise of cloud.
But with cloud,
customers are trying
to do inherently new
and exciting things
that they couldn't do
before, because they
were limited by technology.
And in this case, Optiva, which
is a telecom communications
billing and charging
system, so as mission
critical as they
get, it has basically
adopted Spanner as its next
generation database system
for its next generation software
for billing and charging.
Right.
You know, when they
looked at Spanner,
they saw improved
performance and reliability
from their existing
traditional architectures
and they actually saw 10
times more throughput,
so 10 times more
transactions per second,
at a dramatically reduced cost.
So Optiva is actually presenting
this week at Mobile World
Congress in Barcelona,
and I'm here with you
and I'm not there, but
it's really exciting
because you know they're really
excited about the technology.
They're really excited
about the possibilities
it opens up for them
and for their customers.
And that's really the reason to
have Cloud Spanner as a managed
database service.
They don't have to worry
about the system itself.
And also because
of its combination
of relational semantics
and horizontal scale,
they can do things
with this technology
that they couldn't do with their
existing on prem solutions.
So another interesting example,
one of my favorites actually,
Marketo and the one
following, is again--
Marketo is a marketing
platform that
provides marketing
applications for companies
all over the world.
And for them, in
their own words,
having order sequence in
their application logic
is very important.
And as they were
looking to go to cloud,
and looking obviously--
you know the first step
is which cloud provider do I
use and the second question
for most of us is, well,
what database services do
each of these cloud providers
have and how do I use them?
Is it easier for me
to use these services
or is it going to make
my life more difficult.
And with Cloud Spanner,
basically again they
could use the system to have
the kind of order and sequence
guarantees and
[? the op ?] logic
so they didn't have to
write brittle application
logic to have that sequencing.
With NoSQL and with systems
that are scaled but lacking
in transactional consistency or
strong consistency, all of that
has to be built
into the app, which
means your application
becomes a lot more complicated
and your team is
basically stressing
in keeping that system
alive and running
instead of building cool
things to serve your customers.
That obviously is a
productivity hit, but also
a growth hit for you.
It affects your
business bottom line.
And in this case,
when you don't have
to worry about that anymore,
you can choose Spanner.
You don't have to re-platform
or think of re-platforming ever.
You just grow as your
global business grows.
I mean that's a powerful
statement, right?
And another one of our
favorite customers, Evernote--
I think a lot of
people know Evernote.
Again, they had a multiple
hundred sharded [INAUDIBLE]
SQL system.
They want their users' notes
to be obviously available
no matter where they are.
They, with Cloud Spanner, can
go to a system that reduces this
complexity, gives them scale,
and once they have migrated,
they don't actually have to
think about re-platforming ever
again so it reduces,
in fact eliminates,
all of that stress of managing
the complicated multi shard
MySQL system that keeps
their operations team awake
at night--
from that to building
more functionality
and having an ease of
use of their application
and infrastructure.
So we talked about some of
the positive things in Cloud
Spanner or how it's different
from traditional relational
non-relation databases,
but it's important to note
that Google Cloud Platform's
database portfolio is vast.
and Spanner is one piece of it.
Right.
We actually have Memcache all
the way on the left to our data
warehouse in the
cloud with BigQuery.
So the way I think about
Cloud Spanner and BigQuery,
if you're used to traditional
relational databases and data
warehouses, Cloud
Spanner and BigQuery
are the cloud
equivalents of those.
But it's deliberately
placed next to--
Cloud Spanner is
deliberately placed
next to non-relational
systems in this chart
because it allows you to
have non-relational scale
along with the relational
semantics that it offers.
So you know the whole
portfolio basically
allows you to have
a bunch of tools
that you can choose from to
build the kinds of systems
you need for your application.
We're not trying to tie you down
to one and only one solution,
but we're not giving you
hundreds to choose from.
We think they're
different use cases that
require very specific tailored
solutions for storage.
And with this
portfolio, we basically
offer you a solution for each
of those specific use cases.
What that also
means is, again, you
have the toolkit to
choose the right system,
but you're not left on
your own to figure out
which system you need to use
among hundreds or dozens.
There is, as I said, a solution
for each specific use case.
And we hope you choose the
right system for the use case.
So as this chart shows,
there's basically a flow chart
that you can use to
pick the system you
want for the use case you have.
And this is again up on our
docs in a cloud.google.com
so you can look it up
there as well along
with a lot more information.
So hopefully that
kind of gave you
an overview of why we
think Cloud Spanner is
the future of database systems.
And we'll take a short
break of less than a minute
and come back for a live
Q&A section as well.
So stay tuned.
Welcome back to "Cloud OnAir."
Let's get straight to
our audience questions
for the day from this webinar.
So question 1, are you expecting
all relational databases
to migrate to cloud immediately?
Absolutely not.
Like there are many reasons
why most of the cloud
spend is still--
sorry, most of the IT spend
is still on prem and not
in the cloud as I had
mentioned earlier in my talk.
So we know that these
are early days of cloud.
But what we want to make sure
is that customers understand
that they don't need to shy
away from adopting cloud
because they think
they can't get
the performance or the
semantics that they're
expecting from their
applications in the cloud.
If you're needing horizontal
scale and relational
semantics for
example, you know you
don't have to worry
about not being
able to do that in the cloud,
because, for example, we
have Cloud Spanner
on Google Cloud that
will allow you to have
that without compromises.
So we expect most of
the cloud migration
to have in the next five-ish
years, three to five years,
and beyond.
There are many reasons for not
being in the cloud right now.
As I said, you've
already made commitments.
You've already
bought the machines.
You've already got
data center space.
You've already got co-lo space
for your data infrastructure.
So it will take time, but I
know that a lot of companies
are looking at
migrating to the cloud.
And it's important that they
see the full picture and all
the options available
to them so that they
don't have to shy away from
it for let's say performance
or manageability or
any of those reasons.
So moving on, why not just
use a non-relational database
on prem or in the cloud?
So I think I touched
upon that earlier.
You know, if you want to use
a non-relational database,
that's totally up to you.
However, non-relational
databases
come with the complexity
that we talked about.
Right?
If you need
relational semantics,
and most mission critical
data does, like bank systems,
telco systems,
health care systems,
when you need relational
semantics and you're trying
to use a non-relational
database,
what that means is you've given
up on transactional system,
you've given up on
strong consistency,
you've given on structured
data, you've given up on SQL--
SQL lite is not
the same as equal.
Anybody who's used
a SQL lite system
can know that it's not SQL.
So you've given
up on all of those
to get the scale with these
non-relational databases.
And if that works
for you, great.
But it does mean that
if you need those things
you have to build them
in the application.
And anybody who's even
attempted to build them
knows that this is
super complicated code.
It's got so many
edge cases that you
have to think about
and take care of.
It's brittle, because
actually building--
rolling your own transaction
in the application layer
is hard, or in the sharded
solution, for example,
doing the logic to
join between two shards
and all those kinds of
things are really hard.
And again, if you like doing
that kind of stuff that's
great, but for most
people, they're
trying to just build
their applications
to run their businesses
and they don't want
to worry about these things.
In that case,
non-relational databases
just don't cut it
for what they need.
OK.
What's the difference between
Cloud Spanner and BigQuery?
Can't I just use BigQuery?
So it's basically the difference
between OLTP systems and OLAP
systems.
So are you looking for an
enterprise data warehouse
or are you looking for
a operational mission
critical database?
That is literally when you
would choose one or the other,
with Cloud Spanner
for OLTP systems
and BigQuery for OLAP systems
or enterprise data warehouse.
So if I were to think about
it in the on prem world
or in the traditional
world, it would
be the difference between
Oracle or SQL Server
and [INAUDIBLE] or Teradata.
That's the real difference.
And in fact we're
basically trying
to make it simple for customers
to use our operational data
in a data warehouse with
Cloud Spanner or BigQuery.
So you don't have to like
have complicated tools
for ETLing data out of
your relational database,
out of your
operational database,
and moving into
your data warehouse.
There are simple
tools that we are
working on that will basically
allow you to quickly transfer
data from Cloud Spanner into
BigQuery and then over time
that you don't even have
to do the detail at all.
It can be as simple
as a button thing.
Moving on, does Cloud
Spanner have every feature
that traditional databases do?
No.
It's a different
take on the system.
So there are specific
sort of features
that Cloud Spanner doesn't
have now that we're working on
to fill those gaps,
like DML obviously,
and backups and things like
that, and triggers and queues.
These are all part of
our roadmap, right?
So I would hope that our
audience and our customers
give us some time, because
we just launched last year
and traditional databases have
been around for 30, 40 years.
So we're trying and
moving very fast.
And we're going to close those
relational database feature
gaps that are critical, right?
There are certain
things that are not
critical for relational
databases that somehow
are supposed to be, you know
stored procedures for example.
That's just a way of pushing
down application logic
into the database layer,
which we don't actually
think that's the way we
want to go with our system.
We wanted to have a lean mean
database that can do the things
you need it to do, which
is strong consistency,
traditional--
sorry, transactions, et cetera.
And we want to give this to
you in global scale, right?
But we think that application
developers know best
how to write their
applications and that's
the way we want to
offer this service.
So with Cloud Spanner, with
a new take on databases,
we were able to go back
to first principles
and think about
why databases exist
and what they're needed
for, what they're used for.
And we were able to cut out
all the sort of flack that
has cruft that has been building
up in databases for a while.
And we were able to go back to
first principle for databases
and then provide the features
and functionality that
are truly core for
databases, especially
relational databases.
And as I said, yes, it
doesn't have every feature
right now which we're going
to [INAUDIBLE] but it also
has features that no
other relational database,
or in fact no
other database has,
which is global, strong
consistency, replication out
of the box, and transparent
securities built in
and transparent et cetera.
Next question, why is sharding
a database so difficult?
So if you ever had
to shard a database,
this would be an obvious
question or obvious answer
really.
So think about a database
with a bunch of tables, right?
And now think about the
fact that you can't actually
buy a big enough box to hold all
the data in all those tables.
So what you have to do then is--
and I'm going to simplify here.
There are many things that
go into consideration here.
But at the simplest
level, what you
have to do is basically
take the table--
if you have 10 tables,
take each table
and then put it in a
different database,
because that way at least
the dataset for that table
is going to fit in your
traditional single box machine.
So you have 10 tables across
10 different databases.
So you know it's, of
course you can just
keep using your tooling and
you can keep using transactions
all for within that table or
maybe two tables with a table
and index let's say.
But it behaves exactly the same
as one database for that one
table and its one index.
But if you ever have to do
anything across those tables,
then you have to write
the transaction logic
in the application
to do the join
and to do the
transactions on them.
So you essentially will
have to write the protocol
to commit a transaction
that is done
in a database inside
the application layer
without having the engine
that runs the system.
The database engine is what runs
these transactions, et cetera,
and does the consistency
and guarantees, et cetera.
So to do that in the application
layer is extremely hard
and, as I said, very brittle,
because what happens when one--
if you're doing a two
phase commit, for example,
what happens if one
shard is unavailable
but the other are committed?
So do you roll back that
shard or do you retrial
on the first shard, right?
And what happens if
during the commit
there was a network outage?
So do you know whether the
transaction committed or not?
Like how do you recover from
that state, et cetera, right?
So there's many,
many things that
go into making shard database
work well and all of them
basically make the application
developer's life very hard.
So those are some of
the questions we had.
I don't think we have
any more questions,
so I think we'll call it a day.
And thank you again for
watching and for tuning
into our live webinar.
As I said, we have these live
webinars for "Cloud OnAir"
every Tuesday.
So please log in next
Tuesday for our upcoming
webinars on collaboration
and productivity tools
as well as machine learning
among other topics.
Thank you so much.
Have a great day.